why quality important to you and how did
you begin working from serie first I
should say I was a primary care doc
working in rural remote Northern Ontario
and seeing lots of patients and the
hospital in my clinic and really you
know losing a lot of sleep over how to
give better care in a really resource
constrained setting for Canada that was
a pretty difficult setting and it was a
tough it was a tough job and I think we
struggled on how to do that and I think
we did the best we could in those
circumstances which are still so much
better than what most of the world faces
of course today so I've been thinking
about quality to professional for a long
time
and then I think you know it came to
global health and Public Health and
trying to understand people and patients
and what are we seeing some population
surveys for example it struck me at the
very beginning of my research career
that people are using some services and
not others and so I started asking why
myiasis why are you skipping facilities
why are you bypassing why are you using
the facility for antenatal care but you
would never come back for delivery
what's going on with that yes and that's
actually when the first signs of the
importance of quality emerged from from
our research and the more work I did
with my colleagues in Africa the more
people we asked the more experiments we
performed and the more I read the more I
realized that quality is fundamental to
people in every part of the world and
for every health condition yes they
define it a bit differently you know
people who have a sick child maybe are
immediately focused on the competence of
the provider whereas women for delivery
are more focused on the interpersonal
care but they all want to get better
they all want strong skills and and
respect so it's that body of evidence
and work that really shifted my thinking
too hard to asking the question what's
actually going on in facilities that
people demanded their actions are based
on quality what's actually happening in
the health system and so for the last
several years our team have been looking
at just that question and that's also
leads to to this work on the Atlantic
Global Health Commission to try to
interrogate the the point of
intersection between systems
and users because that's where health
care happens and that's where health is
built it's at least in terms of the
Health Systems contribution to
population health that's where all the
work is done so understanding what
people expectations are and
understanding what it is they actually
get has been a huge preoccupation for me
I think if we don't attend to that the
health system is is I think we forgo a
massive opportunity to improve
population health because I also should
take its place as one of the
determinants of health yes